Welcome to the third course in CS
6250, where we will be discussing network operations
and management. This segment in the course has
three lessons. The first lesson is focused on
software-defined networking, and its role in making
network operations and management easier. The second module
covers traffic engineering, which is the process by
which network operators reconfigure the network to balance
traffic demands across the network. The third lesson covers
network security. We will start with a lesson on
Software Defined Networking. But before we jump into the
details, I'd like to motivate a little bit why.
In particular I plan to tell you about the
role of network operators in running the network. So
what is network management? Network management is the process
of configuring the network to achieve a variety of tasks.
Network configuration achieves a variety of
tasks including balancing traffic load across the
network, achieving various security goals, and
satisfying business relationships that may exist between
the network that's being configured. And
neighboring networks such as the network's upstream
Internet service provider. A key aspect
to network management is configuring the network.
Unfortunately, if the network is not configured correctly, many
things can go wrong. Configuration mistakes can lead to problems,
such as persistent oscillation, whereby, routers can't agree on a
route to a destination. Loops, where packets get stuck in between two or more
routers and never actually make it to
the destination. Partitions, where by the network is
split into two or more segments that are not connected,
and black holes where packets reach a router that does
not know what to do with the packet and drops
it, as opposed to sending on to it's ultimate destination.